الليلة، صور الأقمار الصناعية الجديدة التي حصلت عليها شبكة
سي إن إن تظهر الدمار التام في
أوكرانيا، سأعرض لكم مسرحًا
في المحلات التجارية في محمود، هذا ما هو عليه
الآن هيكل مبنى محاط
بالدمار، سنعرض لكم نفس
الموقع على بعد مسافة قصيرة  منذ عام مضت،
انظر إليها جنبًا إلى جنب، سنوضح أنه
مذهل، انظر إلى هذا الدمار،
والآن دعني أريكم هذا
ما بقي، حسنًا، هذا أعني أنك تبدو
وكأنك تنظر إلى الآثار الرومانية القديمة
هنا، كانت هذه مدرسة
ومجمع سكني، دعنا نريك
نفس المكان قبل عام واحد وتم
محوه فعليًا من الخريطة، وهو أمر
لا يصدق، أعني انظر إلى ذلك جنبًا إلى جنب مع
دمار الحياة والموت،
ومن الواضح الآن إلى أي مدى يرغب بوتين
في الذهاب لإخفاء  الحقيقة من الروس
بشأن حربه يأمر الآن بالقبض على
منتج سينمائي بارز ألكسندر
راديانسكي، سيكون ضيفي
بعد دقيقة واحدة فقط، وقد تم
إنتاج فيلم تزلج تم إنتاجه ورشح لجائزة الأوسكار في
الأفلام الحائزة على جائزة جولدن جلوب، ولد
في كييف ثم عاش فيها  روسيا لمدة عقدين من
الزمن كان صريحا بشأن
معارضته للحرب وهرب من روسيا
عندما غزا بوتين أوكرانيا ولكن الآن
يريده بوتين أن يدفع لأنه يقول
الحقيقة وبالطبع الحقيقة هي
شيء لا يريد بوتين
أن يسمعه الروس.  في
المقدمة مع المزيد من
[موسيقى]
قصة النخبة، بطارية صواريخ باتريوت الأمريكية
تصر روسيا على تدميرها في
كييف. أخبر المسؤولون الأمريكيون شبكة CNN أن النظام
لا يزال قيد التشغيل، لكن هذا انتصار نادر جدًا
لوسائل الإعلام الموالية للكرملين للتقليل من أهمية
تدمير باتريوت الذي تم الترويج له كثيرًا من قبل
كينجالز المقدمة تشمت بأن
صواريخنا التي تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت كانت سريعة جدًا لدرجة أنها
اخترقت الدفاعات الجوية الأوكرانية مثل
سكين من خلال الزبدة، وتضيف أما بالنسبة
للصواريخ الستة التي تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت، فتقول أوكرانيا
إنها أسقطت رقمًا خياليًا
يقوله المذيع وأكثر مما طردناه بالفعل
مسؤولًا أوكرانيًا كبيرًا
يخبر CNN الآن أن أضرارًا طفيفة فقط لحقت
بنظام الدفاع الجوي باتريوت عندما
تم إسقاط إحدى طائرات كينجال على
ارتفاع منخفض صباح الثلاثاء،
وقال المسؤولون إن النظام الأمريكي الصنع سيتم
إصلاحه قريبًا ويجري
الآن تحقيق في كيفية قيام باتريوت  تم
استهداف مكان
آخر، وتقول أوكرانيا إنه تم إحراز تقدم صغير
حول باكموت،
ويبدو أن هذه الصور الليلية تظهر تقدمًا للمدرعات في
الحقول بالخارج،
لكن التلفزيون الحكومي الروسي موجود في
المدينة ويقوم بجولة في الخطوط الأمامية المدمرة
تحت نيران مستمرة مع
مرتزقة فاغنر الذين يقولون إنهم واثقون من أنهم
سوف ننتصر وسوف
نستولي على باكموت في النهاية، هذا ما
أخبره قائد فاغنر لطاقم التلفزيون الروسي الذي
يتبعه ولكن بأي
ثمن لا نعرف، وهو يعترف بأن
آخر يقول إنهم يقصفوننا من
بعيد لأنهم لا يستطيعون هزيمتنا في
قتال متلاحم.  يقول إن
المسؤولين الأوكرانيين يؤكدون أن
القتال العنيف في المدينة الذي تم التقاطه في
أحدث مقطع فيديو بطائرة بدون طيار، قد تم
تدمير مناطق ضواحي الحمامات ولكن يتم
تحريرها الآن، كما يقول الأوكرانيون،
وعلى شاشة التلفزيون الروسي، هناك
قبول متزايد بأن ما كان المقصود منه
هجومًا قصيرًا في أوكرانيا قد أصبح  خرجت
عن نطاق السيطرة لتكشف عن نقاط الضعف
والانقسامات في البلاد،
إنها ليست عملية عسكرية خاصة كما
يقول هذا الضيف على شاشة التلفزيون الرسمي، ولكنها
حرب مصيرية يجب على الروس الفوز بها أو
مواجهة الدمار
بينما تستعد أوكرانيا لهجوم
مضاد لاستعادة
الأراضي المحتلة، يبدو أن روسيا  يستعدون أيضًا للقتال
الليلة أخبرني المسؤولون الأوكرانيون أنهم
يتوقعون المزيد من الهجمات الروسية،
ويقولون إنهم حددوا ما لا يقل عن اثني
عشر قاذفة قنابل روسية بالفعل في الجو
في هذه الأثناء في باتمان، قال زعيم فاغنر
لغينيا بريجوسيان إن
مقاتليه حققوا المزيد  إن المكاسب فيما
تتفق عليه جميع الأطراف الآن بما في ذلك
وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الروسية هي بالمناسبة
معركة مكثفة من أجل تلك المدينة. آرون حسنًا، ماثيو تشانس،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك، أريد
أن أذهب الآن كما وعد ألكسندر
رودنيانسكي، المخرج الذي تحاول روسيا
اعتقاله، لقد غادر  روسيا بعد أن
بدأت الحرب، لقد تحدث مرارًا وتكرارًا
ضدها وألكسندر أنا أقدر جدًا
وقتك، فلنبدأ
هنا الآن، يريد بوتين إلقاء القبض عليك، ماذا
كان رد فعلك عندما اكتشفت الأمر
جيدًا، شكرًا لك على استضافتي، لا شيء
سيصدمني بعد الآن  روسيا
أعتقد أن روسيا دولة
أه تسقط أه إنهم
يضطهدون كل من يحاول
الاحتجاج ومن يحاول أن يتكلم ضد
الحرب ومن يحاول أن يقول الحقيقة التي
كانت تجري ولهذا اعتبرت
هذا الاعتقال والقضية الجنائية ضدي
بمثابة  غرفة نوم شرف
واعتراف رسمي بـ أه كما تعلم من قبل
الدول الروسية لموقفي العالمي بأكمله
أن ما أعتقد أنه
مهم بالنسبة لي لأنه منذ أن
بدأ هذا الغزو في البداية
بدأت أتحدث علنًا ضد الحرب
والمجرمين وأنا  ستقول
الجرائم العسكرية أه التي ارتكبها
الجيش الروسي في موطني أوكرانيا،
لذلك قالت الناشطة الروسية ألكسندر
المقيمة في الولايات المتحدة
اليوم إنها تشتبه في أنها
تعرضت للتسمم خلال رحلة قامت بها مؤخرًا إلى أوروبا
ونعلم بالطبع أن بوتين أظهر ذلك  لا داعي
للخوف من تسميم الناس آه، كما تعلم، انظر
إلى شوارع لندن في شوارع
المدن في المملكة المتحدة ولكن هذا
مقرها في الناشطة الروسية الأمريكية
تعتقد أن هذا حدث لها في
أوروبا، هل أنت قلق بشأن
سلامتك أعني بوضوح أنك'  لست في
روسيا ولكن هل لديك تلك المخاوف
ألكساندر،
لم أعد موجودًا في روسيا بالطبع ولكني
أعرف مدى فعالية
المخابرات الروسية في متابعة أه الأشخاص
الذين يحتجون على النظام الروسي
وما يحدث الآن أعتقد أن
هذا هو  بالأحرى ترهيب
أولئك الذين بقوا في روسيا، لذا فلا بأس
بالنسبة لي، ليس لدي خوف من أن لا شيء
يمنعني من قول الحقيقة
حول ما يجري في أوكرانيا
ومع هذه الحرب بالتأكيد سأفعل ذلك
وأكثر من ذلك معظم أصدقائي  يحاولون أن
يخبروني أنهم يجب أن يكونوا حذرين للغاية
وسأكون حذرًا للغاية ولكني سأفعل
ما فعلته والأهم من ذلك أنني أشعر
بشدة، كما تعلمون الدعم القوي من العديد من
الأشخاص الذين ما زالوا يعيشون في روسيا
ويحاولون دعمي من  هناك